[Música]
y
sí
[Música]
e
y
[Música]
e
ah
[Aplausos]
para qué sirve la música muchos
responderían para divertirse
entretenerse o relajarse y es cierto
sería muy difícil encontrar a un ser
humano en el mundo al que no le guste la
música la música es en mayor o menor
medida parte de la vida de todos todos
somos por lo menos consumidores de
música algunas personas son intérpretes
y otros cuantos más creadores
esto es producen y reproduce la música
para el disfrute de uno mismo o el de
otras personas cuando tenía cinco años
no me hizo un regalo extraordinario me
dio un violín resulta que en mi escuela
tenía la buena idea de que todos los
niños aprendieron a tocar violín a
partir de los 3 años así que todos lo
hacíamos todos adquirimos poco a poco la
habilidad de producir sonidos más o
menos melodiosos desde el diplomático
instrumento
en ese entonces yo no lo sabía en
realidad son muy pocas las personas no
son pocas las escuelas que dan tanta
importancia a la música en la educación
una de las primeras personas que pensó
que los niños podrían y deberían
aprender a tocar un instrumento musical
en los primeros años de su vida fue sin
lichi su team suzuki funda la persona
que dedicó gran parte de su vida al
estudio de violín nació el 7 de octubre
de 1998 en japon hijo de un fabricante
de violines y desde su amor y su pasión
a la música inició sus estudios de
violín en el conservatorio de tokio en
1915 luego más tarde a los 26 años de
edad
se fue a berlín alemania para practicar
el violín y es ahí en donde cuando has
ido a nadie más que el mismísimo albert
eisntein como dato curioso les contaré
que albert einsten en un gran aficionada
del violín después suzuki decide volver
a japón para transmitir sus
conocimientos a los niños chiquitos es
cuando se le ocurre y todos los niños
logran aprender a hablar no importa la
dificultad de la lengua materna porque
no hace lo mismo con la música y con esa
idea hizo el método suzuki que es un
método que para que un niño aprenda a
tocar un instrumento musical de una
manera más natural el método está
enfocado principalmente para los niños
pero puede ser un buen método para un
adulto que esté interesado en aprender
el violín
aunque su sufrir se enfocó
principalmente en el violín este método
ha sido utilizado en otros instrumentos
hay cuatro ideas primordiales en la
filosofía de suzuki la primera el ser
humano es producto del ambiente en el
que lo rodean se refiere que si un niño
crece en un ambiente enriquecido y
estimulante su cerebro se va a
desarrollar más y mejor que el de uno en
un ambiente limitado y poco estimulante
la segunda cuanto antes mejor no son la
música sin el aprendizaje se refiere a
que cuanta más temprana edad uno empiece
a aprender a tocar música mejor lo hará
cuando crezca tercera idea la repetición
de las experiencias es importante para
el aprendizaje las experiencias que se
repiten son conexiones neuronales que en
el cerebro que se refuerzan en el violín
se refiere a practicar y practicar y
practicar todas las piezas aún las que
hayas aprendido tiempo atrás ya que con
la repetición de las pisadas
creas nuevas piezas tomando fuera del
contexto del violín cualquier cosa que
hagas con la suficiente
duración intensidad y repetición quedará
grabado firmemente en nuestro cerebro
4 tanto los maestros los estudiantes
como los padres deben ser parte del
desarrollo del niño para crear un
ambiente más favorable para su educación
el maestro sí sí sí el macho sentí y
suzuki murió a los 99 años de edad pero
su legado sigue vivo y puedo decir que
toco mi vida la importancia de que los
niños aprendan música con el método
suzuki o con cualquier otro método es
para mejorar su coordinación en el
cerebro pero tú de seguramente te
estarás preguntando cómo es el hecho de
que toca el violín va a ayudarme a mi
cerebro cuando tocas el violín se
activan varias partes del cerebro que
usamos en la vida cotidiana
por ejemplo la lógica la coordinación la
movilidad la memoria etcétera en los
últimos años se han hecho gran y gran
cantidad de investigaciones científicas
conforme al impacto de la educación
musical en el cerebro lo que parece
evidente es que la fisiología del
cerebro aumenta grandemente cuando uno
toca la música eso es aprender a tocar
un instrumento musical cambia
físicamente y para bien tu cerebro
luz aunque investigador del instituto
tecnológico de zúrich
sostiene que la educación musical ayuda
a las habilidades del lenguaje la
memoria la conducta y la inteligencia
espacial esta última se refiere a la
habilidad de crear imágenes mentales
sobre el mundo que nos rodea
la inteligencia espacial nos ayuda a
resolver problemas cognitivos complejos
pero también nos ayuda a resolver
problemas que usamos en la vida
cotidiana
por ejemplo preparar el almuerzo te
posar como investigador de la
universidad de helsinki opina que la
música puede incluso ayudar a personas
que han sufrido lesiones cerebrales
para recuperar y mejorar sus habilidades
de habilidades fisiológicas
en sus estudios sus pacientes no sólo me
mejoraron su
su capacidad de atención y su memoria
verbal y lo que también mejoran su
estado de ánimo en otras palabras la
música es tan buena para la mente como
para el alma por más de 10 años se ha he
aprendido y practicado el violín al
principio no me gustaba mucho pero no le
digan a mi mamá
me aburría un poco pero estoy feliz de
haber perseverado y que mi mamá haya
insistido en ello ya que hoy disfruto
mucho de la música que busco como
pudieron ver
y mi violín es un gran compañero con él
es superado varios retos
hace poco participe en dos orquestas
modernas y en un ensamble esos dos
fueron retos ya que tuve que practicar
todos los días pero sin descuidarse de
mis tareas y mis estudios escolares
desde los 5 años he aprendido y
practicado el violín en clases
particulares o en la escuela además de
los logros que ha obtenido en el
instrumento me he dado cuenta que ha
mejorado mi memoria y mi rapidez
cerebral ya que puedo acordarme de
piezas que no he tocado en ya bastante
tiempo y que también para los exámenes
solo tengo que darle una auto repasadas
para acordarme de lo que el profesor
dijo en clase
la música nos desarrolla el cerebro nos
hace más disciplinados y perseverantes
nos mejoran la memoria los hace más
creativos y sensibles pero más
importante nos hace estar en contacto
frecuente con la parte más humana de un
nuevo mismo la música es una gran
maestra entonces porque su trabajo en
las escuelas ha sido minimizado o hasta
en algunas ocasiones ignorado
completamente el último fin de la
educación es crear mejores seres humanos
y la música cumple justamente con ese
propósito gracias
[Aplausos]
i
y
[Música]